welcome to this video playing Frank add
a teammate of mine let's see ya play
some some other stuff d 6 g 6 hey place
this Bishop c4 stuff I know that mm-hmm
I mean I know that he plays it but I
really don't know anything about it so
I'll do something fun even go go for it
go for a proper Thomas let's see what is
coming up with it's not the kind of
position that you break down easy easily
Black is not very active that's clear
but I mean you're not going to Toulouse
quickly or something let's see I need to
to put something in the center I Bishop
f4 yeah I didn't really appreciate that
about ok let's play you five the kind of
position that somewhat resembles the the
ruler person away from black from black
point of view you know it's not not that
far away from the room
I guess Quincy so now I have to get out
of the default k h6 attacked yeah should
I flick in c4 now it's not necessary i
think yeah here i have Knight f6
actually or is Queen d6 problem maybe
maybe him up the 826
I thought Knight f6 originally but
that's not grade now maybe I so should
do it 26 is annoying maybe this is
really a bad bad for me I mean after
Queen d6 at the end there is now this
all this stuff hanging maybe I can take
night c 8 yeah this actually hurts the
forum at least for the moment it's quite
ugly but I mean I thought see how to
keep the keeper keep stuff protected
okay let's see can he cannot really
exchange our okay yeah I mean I need to
take it and what is this at the end yeah
if we after the smoke clears this is a
piece for two pawns right but somewhat
hard to believe a five at the end or
what exactly I don't know what the most
precise way to play this but yes it yes
it take the exchange I mean otherwise
it's it's like a rook look for two
points i cannot believe at all okay but
the thing is he's not so easily
advancing the pawns i can go if i go
there now would i will i will have a
quick ever have quick pressure on e4 as
well so look at the 894 i can just take
your form due to the week back rank 94
94 94 yeah i can just take them
the week back rank of white
if it loses that you fall porn I mean
the whole backbone of the position is
falling apart Bishop takes to ensure
more trades probably yeah I guess you
cannot really avoid the bishop trade now
okay yeah I'm Knight d2 or 92 or what
night 96 also possible on 95 it probably
does not matter very much um yeah here i
can i can actually take check and and
rook Jack 93 winning the rook check
check right King is somewhat far away
but I cannot believe the pawns are that
dangerous really let's see just get the
king over yeah get the king over quickly
and always have to be cautious those
pawns but I should be quick enough with
the King would be really weird now I get
in King e6 very quickly b5 I will take
king d6 and c5 I give the check and then
go to d1 fighting the pawns from the
back that that should win
okay miss may be playing King c5 if I go
the app it's still I should do that it's
not okay maybe Brooke a one I guess I'm
attack the avon and King now King b6
that's real gave one yeah just take here
I guess
Joe my king is now near the hole the
hope the whole proceeding so this should
should save the day um gather the check
but how do I actually win now to be
honest that was really strong turning
how do I win now may be running out of
moves here wow how stupid was that
really after f5 I mean zoosk while they
cannot win this how stupid did I play
that okay that's that's really
disappointing I mean I also cannot
cannot really lose it but because of the
the stain medium but I screw this up
terribly
yeah it's always a stalemate not very
very weird
stalemate I can wow I really I what did
i do here I am maybe this isn't this
isn't that clear-cut boys it's just I
mean it's a matter of Tempe also what
did I do wrong here King b7 is coming
this one
yeah this is actually winning up due to
a funny funny zoosk wrong idea this kind
of thing it's really cute if white takes
its at this kind of situation where he
runs out of moves and ultimately I will
win this but this is like study study
like win which I definitely shouldn't
need here here of course I mean this is
this is just just totally it's totally
stupid how did i do that if i go here
then there's a seven and I've even
losing so what should I just take here
actually I want some some simple win no
not something where I need to study yeah
this is winning this is winning i'm
getting in front of the pawns now yeah
this is the easiest way to do it Wow has
screwed this up royally yeah those
points they are always dangerous but
yeah yeah and now i will i didn't i
didn't see it really I couldn't I
couldn't figure out that this is since
the in fact the wind if I let him take
the rook maybe maybe they all win yeah
no f5 not i mean the comp is giving g5
is the win what about this king be so
they're probably just this right yeah
this is this is always winning that
that's really really funny because now
White has to I mean I just what has to
move and it's it's a zoosk one something
like that really really funny okay this
was what's interesting thanks for
watching